so Donald Trump and his staff and many
right-wing media outlets have been
aggressively bragging about the increase
of the value of the stock market usually
they point to the Dow which is a price
weighted average of 30 companies and
it's often looked at it's kind of an
indicator of how the stock market at
large is doing here for example is Trump
bragging about the stock market recently
on Twitter where he said quote stock
market could hit all-time high
again 22,000 today was 18,000 only six
months ago on election day mainstream
media seldom mentioned now I've talked
before about how I am in the market very
very broadly I mostly just believe in
investing in index funds at the lowest
possible cost over the long term so yeah
it's true stocks are up and they've been
making money for investigate investors
for some months the problem is the stock
market particularly the Dow it's not
really a good indication of how the
economy is doing for the average
American not every American owned stocks
and even among those Americans that do
own stocks the overwhelming majority of
the shares are held by the really rich
something that much more directly impact
the average American is the value of the
American dollar which Donald Trump
hasn't been talked about which has
crashed over the last six months
check out the dollar index which we have
on the screen right now the dollar as
you can see by this image starting back
in January around Donald Trump's
election the dollar has been
consistently falling as Donald Trump has
done any number of questionable things
with firing James Comey threatening
China around trade whatever it is this
impacts people the dollar strength is
relative to other currencies and
inflation tells us how it has changed in
value relative to what things cost in
the United States so the exchange rate
alone doesn't tell us that much it's
sort of a combination of the rate and
the purchasing power of those dollars or
the currency that you're changing
dollars into the Consumer Price Index
measures how much you can buy with the
dollars that you have a weak dollar can
be a sign of an upcoming downturn in the
economy we've
talking about that and that is
absolutely a concern a falling dollar
can also signal upcoming inflation for
example and when you have a strong
dollar Americans can buy more stuff
either when they travel or in terms of
imported goods weak dollar makes the
stuff we export cheaper so we can
increase GDP since foreign countries
would conceivably buy more of our
exports since they're cheaper in their
currency the problem is though that if
the US doesn't produce the type of cheap
goods that will be bought more quickly
with a weak dollar which we don't
it doesn't really benefit us that much
and a weak dollar can lead to stagnant
wages which is and has been a problem in
the United States Travel becomes more
expensive for Americans and you know who
does benefit from a weaker dollar
stockholders of multinational companies
that's interesting
but Trump is silent doesn't even mention
the fact that the value of the dollar
pat has fallen off of a cliff since he's
been president
oh yeah Trump loves to mention how he's
created 1 million jobs since he took
office or how unemployment's at a 16
year low and that the Dow Jones is at
22,000 now but and of course he ignores
the things that are negative indicators
of the economy not only that he even is
using evidence he believed to be
doctored under Obama now to defend his
economy like the same Bureau of Labor
Statistics numbers that were fake under
Obama are now the exact same numbers
that he uses to justify his strength of
some kind of steward of the economy even
just repeating the jobs numbers as they
are now or the unemployment numbers it
completely removed the context of the
position that he inherited himself
taking over Obama's economy completely
ignores it and we kind of have a good
sense that Trump doesn't understand
currency because we know that he called
disgraced former national security
adviser Michael Flynn at 3:00 a.m. once
to ask them whether a strong dollar or
weak dollar were better and of course
Michael Flynn was national security
adviser not exactly the first guy you
think of when you've got questions about
today's program is brought to you by
movement
to MGMT now you probably know movement
because they've been talking to you
about their watches including the one
that I'm wearing today for probably over
a year at this point and they've sold
over a million watches to date and they
are doing it again but this time with
sunglasses they were tired of having to
pay for these cheaply made throwaway
sunglasses or the overpriced designer
sunglasses so they said screw it we're
going to make our own starting at just
70
of these sunglasses I constantly am
either misplacing once I actually found
my sunglasses underneath the wheel of my
car seven days after I had lost them and
once I just lost a pair of sunglasses on
the golf course and very easily they get
damaged etc I've had these movement
sunglasses for about a month now
wherever I go people say that's a really
nice looking pair of sunglasses people
ask me about it where'd you get that
what do they cost they've got a varied
selection of styles and you can also
find the perfect pair for you risk free
with free shipping and free returns the
glasses start at 70 bucks with the
option to upgrade to polarized that many
of those designer brands will run you
over $200 and as usual movement cuts out
the middleman to save you you can get
15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t.com slash
Pakman you know movement for how they
revolutionize the watch industry and now
you can check out their sunglasses MVM t
comm /p a que ma n